Khanh retirement age many look forward
to enjoying the fruits of years of hard
work but if you're a female pensioner in
Europe you could fall short of your
financial needs in old age women get 40%
less pension than their male
counterparts this is only one of many
areas where inequality between men and
women stubbornly exists we should take
gender issues very seriously if this has
not been the case in the last year's I
believe because due to the crisis the
gender with gender equality has been
done grated on average more women in the
EU complete tertiary education than men
but they still make less money in the
boardroom of big publicly listed
companies less than a quarter are women
the higher up the corporate structure
the lower the figure while almost
two-thirds of women are employed a third
work part-time
almost half of whom do so because of
family and care related reasons the EU
Parliament wants to speed up progress in
closing the gap we need to move forward
the agenda for the maternity and
paternity leave we want a binding
instrument against age and violence we
need the gender equality back at the top
of the political agenda the 11 if no
significant changes are made it would
take Europe 70 years before equal pay is
achieved 40 years before housework is
equally shared and twenty years before
gender balance in politics is achieved